Brady Quinn Brady's on the call with Joe
Davis Bruce Feldman
on the sidelines it's USC vs. Stanford
Saturday 8:30 Eastern on Fox Brady joins
us this morning from Palo Alto
good morning Brady how are you I'm doing
great I got a stat for you
it's a Brady Quinn stat did you know
love it you're the only Notre Dame
quarterback in school history to go for
no against Stanford and oh and four
against USC yeah the the state of
California is interesting like that
right like I I much prefer to work a
little bit with a little more of a wine
drinker less less of a peach guy so
maybe maybe that is something to do it
I'm not sure how often are you asked
about Notre Dame USC I was asked about
it this past this past week because of
Notre Dame Michigan robbery and you know
which ones you you kind of prioritize or
which one which one do you think is you
know the biggest in your mind as a
player and so you've asked about it a
fair amount and I think that the biggest
difference you know between USC then and
now is just you know the recruiting
classes are about as good but not quite
to the extent of what they were then I
mean they were getting everyone and
those teams when you look at that where
those guys were drafted and all the
talent they had on those teams
incredibly different time different era
then also Stanford as well that was a
different feel like Harbaugh came in and
changed the whole culture at Stanford
right right like now the you know exotic
you know style of play is bringing in
extra tight ends and linemen to run the
football in college football and you
know he was kind of one of the guys to
do that I think he also recruited fellow
I mean look at the quarterbacks they
were able to get at that point I'm not
that Stanford didn't before either I
mean they had some highly ranked
quarterbacks coming out of high school I
just think you know Harbaugh was able to
find a way of making what they could
recruit around the quarterback work with
the system are we being too harsh on
Michigan and Harbaugh that they can't
win on the road they don't build they
don't beat ranked opponents on the road
they're not beating the best teams in
the Big Ten
or should we be taking the magnifying
glass to Jim horrible well I think we
should be especially at this point
considering how long he's been there but
I I still think you're asking a lot of
any team I don't care what level when
you've got two new offensive coordinator
to come in and Ed Warner Jim McLain a
graduate transfer who comes in basically
you know the summertime to be able to
figure this offense out and then asking
them to go win a road game versus a
really good opponent in her game to
start the season
like it's just a lot to ask and you know
if they'd lost by a touchdown I think
they'll get better as this season goes
along yeah I think it and they could
still win the Big Ten and they could
still go potentially college football
playoff if they do that so you know I
know everyone's kind of saw the skies
falling there but I don't think that's
the case there's two Talent but if a
teen I think they'll eventually figure
it out you know you bring up a great
point you have new coordinators and
offensive minded people in there and I
had a college assistant coach tell me
from a different school too many cooks
in there that that because I said you
know how would you look at Notre Dame
Michigan and he said from afar I would
say too many cooks in there as far as
trying to make the recipe on offense and
that's a recipe for disaster
sometimes I can be the case so I
delegate to quarterback system
I don't really know anyone who can make
that work and maybe that's the case to
do it play calling it seems like that
eventually comes to an end even at TCU
for example sunny company doesn't eat
them we can I had a nice one there with
Gary Patterson for a while but
eventually there's a breakup so it seems
like it's just hard to make it work
because it's such a ego driven and
ultimately I think you know when you're
put in a position where one way or
another you're either gonna get the
praise of the blame you'd like it all to
be on you and not have to split with
someone else and then that's where you
start pointing fingers so I think that's
the other reason why it really comes
down to you know always better really
having one guy one voice that's saying
everything and calling the play and
making the decision
number 17 USC what jumped out at you
after their first win against UNLV just
the poise of their freshman quarterback
I mean how a young man can step on a
stage like that performed the way he did
I'd be so poised and calm almost bid
on a replica of Sam Donald but very
similar in the sense of similar release
accurate quarterbacks that quick release
he's shifty enough not as good as a
runner but just the poise that he showed
not really panicking when they cast role
a little bit early on versus UNLV what
about Stanford what stood out there
their opener and the fact that Bryce
loves struggle to run the football I
mean you know he's a Heisman candidate
you kind of expect now one of these big
performances to jump on the scene at the
beginning of the year and didn't happen
and it ended up being the passing game
KJ costella and our Saiga white side
connecting for three touchdowns helped
open things up and they're probably
gonna have to do that the rest of the
year to prove to teams that they can
throw the football and you can't just
load up the box to stop rice love
talking a Brady Quinn he's got USC and
Stanford coming up Saturday night at
8:30 Eastern on Fox you talked about the
poise of JT Daniels and the number of
freshmen who are coming in now and
they're ready to play now and this goes
back to high school grade school it's
it's like there's this I like a
laboratory Brady that you know we're
teaching these kids of how to under what
to understand about the game and and
they're ready to go they're running
their own offense in kinda high school
here like how surprising is it that
you're seeing this many freshman
quarterbacks contribute it's a bit
surprising but it just it speaks to I
think the game of football how big it is
and then how big the most important
position is in the game of football and
it speaks to all the coaches out there
who are working with them with a high
school coach or you know these these
quarterback gurus either way they're
preparing these young men for the moment
and they come in technically more ready
than ever before they have a better
football IQ as far as what to expect and
and I think it's a good thing for the
game of football especially at the
highest level right because we want
these guys coming in understanding the
game the different nuances so we can
replace the Tom Brady's the Aaron
Rodgers the trooper ease of the world at
some point so I think it's a great thing
for college football look look I love
the game I think all these guys who play
the quarterback position end up becoming
leaders in something else
eventually whenever the
GameStop's for them they don't end up
you know one day leading a company or
becoming a CEO and I always think the
lessons these guys are coming in with
how much maturity they could show at a
young age pretty impressive but I'm also
hearing you got kids who are six and
seven years of age where dad is sending
their tapes to God took guys to analyze
what their kids are doing at five and
six Brady yeah and that's the crazy part
sounds like that the European model
right my wife was an Olympic gymnast you
know so back in 2008 she's competing for
our country over in Beijing and if you
want to know when they ended up figuring
out whether or not she could you know do
gymnastics her coach selected her around
five years old six years old I mean at
that point time he knew he saw something
in her we thought it was worth his time
to invest with her and she could
eventually make it to the Olympics so
you know I'm not sure whether it's right
or wrong I do know it's something that
it's becoming more prevalent than before
and I think over time as long as the
parents are able to find that that
balance I think it can be a good thing I
really do I didn't know your wife was an
Olympic gymnast really hey come on DP I
don't think so did she ever go to party
and like do handstands or backflip and
things like that he was pretty much he
was so inebriated at that point you
could have pushed him with your pinky
finger would have fell over yeah do you
guys have that we sure did we do not
know who his wife was and now we put two
and two together we've seen this video
before she knocked some guy that you
know what else is she proud of this
video Brady oh I know that combination
quite well
the sneaky Heisman sleeper who would be
your sneaky Heisman candidate we're
already a weekend I wish would ask me
this you know ten days ago I would have
said will career me because I don't know
buddy no that's not
sleeper yeah yeah booty it's tough
because you've got to pick someone who
you know maybe maybe you haven't you
know maybe we didn't hear and it was
able to build enough equity last year
right I got ways look at the highs and
races it's hard I think to win with no
one knows who you are coming into the
season like you can have a great year
but you've got to have a little bit of
high blood equity you got to be a top
recruit or something else trying to
think you know what I really like I
don't think he gets enough attention I
don't know that he will but sleepers
just until running back for Oklahoma
State he is phenomenal he might be one
of the best running backs all the way
around
I mean catches well runs well and and
really you know blocks his unselfish
helps out his teammates but he's a guy
that should get more credit for more
hype and maybe if they're sneaky good in
the big 12 you know baby
what sitting with that offenses
production maybe we do hear more about
him I still love that story where Barry
Switzer told his team not to injure
Thurman Thomas at Oklahoma State because
Barry Sanders was behind Thurman Thomas
and Barry Switzer new injures Thurman we
have to face Barry so he told his
defense whatever you do do not hurt
Thurman Thomas that's how good Barry was
mistaken Mike Gundy was the quarterback
yeah I think so Hartley dykes was on
that team too is that sound right Mike
because when I get on the liner all the
time because I'm like good running back
but we always said like when I play the
can't see so I said the best seat in the
house was watching Jamal Charles run
after him the football office or our
quarterback coach used to get on me for
not booting away and all that but it was
hard not to stand back and watch it just
kind of the greatness that they were
bring to the position but the liner
fully acknowledges that he got Reggie
Bush pushing him into the end zone and
southbend right the bush push he
acknowledges it down right yeah well
there's the rule now you can push him
and you can't pull him so now he feels
vindicated it was a crime back and here
like insider trading but it's not
now he's grandfathered in yeah yeah he
feels completely vindicated by it so I
think they're okay have fun this weekend
Thank You Brady tell the boys we set a
low and safe travels
thank you will Brady Quinn Brady with
Joe Davis and Bruce Feldman they've got
8:30 Eastern on Fox USC versus Stanford
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]